well a paternity case might be exactly
what we needed to get the details behind
the Biden's family Shady business
dealings now in the words of Joe no joke
the judge today ordered Hunter Biden to
provide written answers and sit for a
deposition next month on overseas
funding that he's received any documents
on the work he did with Chinese energy
companies and details on his art sales
now I wonder if alcohol could have been
avoided if the bidens just acknowledged
this poor little child in the first
place joining me now Miranda Devine New
York Post columnist and Fox News
contributor Miranda this kind of reminds
me of like getting one of the old
gangsters right on a tax you know
violation like you know getting getting
Capone on the tax tax fraud instead of
what he actually really did
well I guess for Hunter Biden's very
expensive lawyers it's like whack-a-mole
at the moment they really are very very
busy whether it's Delaware or the
Republicans in Washington DC looking at
the money Trail or Batesville Arkansas
where London Roberts is just trying to
get Hunter Biden to continue to pay the
child support that he agreed to there's
a lot of financial transactions that
Hunter Biden has kept secret from the
world and that I'm sure his father and
the White House don't want publicized
either but as you say it may be this
little tiny courthouse in Batesville
Arkansas and this Plucky young woman
London Roberts who's insisting no matter
how much pressure she's placed on she is
insisting that her four-year-old
daughter Hunter Biden's daughter gets
her just desserts
well house oversight committee chair
Miranda Jim Comer he had an interesting
Revelation I thought this morning
in communication with our Witnesses and
with people who are cooperating from a
subpoena standpoint we know that they've
been contacted by the attorneys for
Hunter Biden we feel that this is really
close to crossing the line obviously
they're objective in my opinion is
witness intimidation this will not stand
we're going to continue to press forward
Miranda witness intimidation does this
surprise you
not at all Hunter has the best attorneys
money can buy teams and teams of them
who is paying for them well it's these
Democrat dark money groups these are
gifts that he's been given presumably
they should be subject to tax and at
least they should be subject to London
Roberts child support so it is a
scorched Earth policy that they're
pursuing they are intimidating Witnesses
left right and Center they are going to
go after uh they are going after right
now Jim Comer in Kentucky they've put up
Billboards traducing him they are
traducing the lawyer of London Roberts
this small town Arkansas lawyer expert
witness Garrett Ziegler they are going
after all of them anybody who dares
stick their head above the parapet and
try and hold the Biden family
accountable for whatever whether it's
not paying child support or tax evasion
or any of these other well I'm just glad
you're here that have come up in the
last three years yeah yeah Miranda I'm
just glad you you're still able to come
out and talk great to see you tonight
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else